welcome to Tamra just saw for the ball
juggler buzzbuzz bumpers on June like a
pleasure sir
roller coaster oh dang root beer still
popcorn Wendy got it all
hi guys today I went and watched the
Great Wall
I'm going to give my initial thoughts
and I think we can all agree that I
should just keep out any obvious and
easy wall jokes great good I also really
don't know what constitutes as a spoiler
and what doesn't
there's nothing in the film that that
you need to not know like there's no
it's not like a new Star Wars film or
something crazy happens there's no twist
so I don't think anything I'm going to
say is a spoiler if you know the general
premise of the movie then that's what
I'm going to talk about but you've been
warned this is a spoiler free spoiler
filled reaction to tissue
okay so pleasantly surprised I didn't
know anything about this movie going
into it I just thought that they were
casting Matt Damon as an Asian actor
character human and I was like so I knew
it was getting a lot of controversy I
thought that's where they were going
with the controversy I guess people are
people are upset because Matt Damon is
in an Asian Phil's wonderful acted movie
with great Asian actors like a famous
Chinese director which is really cool um
and then it's just it's Matt Damon being
Matt Damon and he did a good job in the
film I think I don't think he was bad by
any means he there's actually a lot of
moments where he's super badass his
dialect is a little questionable we're
all walking misses I don't even know
what dialect it was supposed to be so
wonky it was this weird mix of like I'm
Matt Damon this is an action film and
then like actual really cool Chinese
culture and like it a really cool
Chinese film doesn't
match so weird the first very first
fight that you see that's taking place
on the wall is fellow badass and he is
so cool in it Matt Damon and other white
men are going to the great wall to try
to get black powder gunpowder and they
were like it's going to make the weapon
of our dreams and it is interesting it I
don't know that I've ever seen a movie
where the main premise was to get
gunpowder because there aren't guns yet
that's kind of cool the weaponry was
awesome like all the swords and all of
the bows arrows I want to know how
accurate this was to things that they
actually did okay getting ahead of
myself in so in this army on the great
wall there are like a lot of soldiers
and they're all wearing different
outfits for what their special skill set
is and there's this awesome group of
women who are in like really cool blue
outfits that are just like damn girl you
good you do great keep doing you awesome
and they were like general soldiers but
they also were doing this thing where
they were jumping off the side of the
wall and spearing things and then being
like Bungie back up so that was cool
did they do that was that an actual
thing that they did I feel like it's not
but maybe so basically the whole movie
is about a specific legend of what the
wall protected the beginning was really
cool was like the Great Wall has
protected from all this stuff um truth
and legend and this is one of the
legends and so you're like oh cool we
like monster that's awesome um I don't
know much about Chinese like folklore
and legend but that's pretty sweet and
then you see the monster I don't know if
it's a spoiler or not but I'm and then
talk about it you see the monster and
it's a little disappointing it kind of
looks like a gremlin dog like a gremlin
from the movie gremlins mixed with a dog
mixed with like weird that dinosaur that
yells and his little like collar pops up
kind of one of those so enough not bad
but not like it absolutely awesome and
and and those are the only monsters in
the whole museum maybe like like
different kinds or like I don't know I
thought it would be more than that it's
a little underwhelming with the monster
aspect can you stop calling it things
please thank you Mike I wrote so many
female soldiers awesome women to the
front
cuz females are strong as hell you guys
watched Kimmy Schmidt
it's like worth it alone just for the
theme song it's so good anyways I put
Willem Dafoe is in this so I kept saying
William Dafoe is the chocolate and
everything review I did so sorry I don't
know things good can you can have a
popcorn Mike has literally just put her
whole hand in the popcorn do you want
one here
yup cute it's too big for her mouth so
she's gotta eat it a little section um
but anyways Willem Dafoe is in this and
she is why uh I'm not sure why he was
needed I don't think he brought anything
special to the role if I'm being very
honest I like him a lot like in most
things that I see this is probably the
one thing that I'm like ah well it's
Willem right the whole conflict is a
cosmic you've seen a million times it's
like oh I'm this really burners guy and
I'm a soldier and I fight for no one but
myself so he's trying to go get money by
getting the the Gunpowder and then he
meets this general general commander
Lynn who is an awesome really cool
female general or commander or whatever
she is then he for some reason needs to
get her trust and I like so there's no
romantic mission between them though
there's chemistry for sure you can have
chemistry without having it need to be
romantic and and I love that at the end
there was a moment where they totally
could have cast like I really liked that
they didn't because they were like
vegetable soldiers with each other I
think if they would have kissed it would
have diminished her power for some
reason in my mind um whatever anyway
that's my field and that Damon really
didn't need to be there but yeah Matt
Damon really didn't need to be in it for
what it was it was fine
like I I think I went in more negatively
than I came out which is that's always
good I was worried that it was going to
be a giant issue for me to have Matt
Damon in this role but I thought that he
was supposed to be an Asian character so
she wasn't so good I did no research
obviously good job Samara um but are you
trying to get popcorn there's no more
here it's over here this isn't a movie
that's going to change your life by any
means it's one of those like I don't
have to space any sense to anyone else
but it's a dad movie it's a movie that
liked well let's go see something to the
theater I really want to do that great
wall movie or like I really want to see
that what's another dad movie
Pacific Rim like those kind of movies
like the newer Hercules with Dwayne the
rock Johnson that's a dad movie like
things like that or it's like this is an
action film but it's not like a great I
don't like 300 the 300 was enjoyable but
I watched that when I still live with my
parents so maybe maybe I was sucked into
the dad movie dad movie phenomenon dad
movie didn't even know it also there
were two other people in my theater and
this is the first or second day that
it's been out so a granted I wanted 11
and that's not a movie going time but
but seems so empty and the silence was
deafening yeah it's definitely not
something that I hated for sure I
enjoyed it I thought some of the action
was really cool the end was very epic so
very heavy and like special effects I
don't recommend the seeing it in the
theater I don't think like whereas last
week I did John went to definitely see
John with to the theater go right now if
you haven't done that leave your
computer screen and go
d oh I should watching Go Go
watch it at home with some beer it'll be
way better don't drink and drive a drink
before you're supposed to drugs my
favorite thing about the power rangers
trailer is the one girl who says that
line so dramatic so dramatically she's
like we're all screw up we're all
screw-ups and she's exposition this is
through gzx 50% I can't wait
transformers what is this transformers
15 no interest in that Logan yes Dunkirk
that looks really awesome Wendy don't
lick the butter say to the Furious I
don't love Tom Cruise and the premise
was kind of done but I still want to see
The Mummy movies to play wrote oh yeah
so this little one plays aah that was
scary just saw and thanks for watching
I'll see you guys next week bye